une violente explosion a ravagé de
théâtre de l'empiré à paris ce matin
sept blessés légers la déflagration
était telle qu'il ne reste rien de la
salle et du balcon l'explosion ne serait
pas lié aux travaux qui étaient en cours
dans le théâtre
une tour de 106 mètres de haut en plein
centre de madrid dévorés par les flammes
mais aucune victime pendant 14 heures
les pompiers ont lutté il ne reste que
des structures qui menace de s'effondrer
à périmètre de sécurité a été mis en
place
personnage clé dans l'affairé elf alfred
servat emporte son mystère avec lui il
est mort d'une crise cardiaque chez lui
il avait 77 ans une vie tumultueuse
quatre années en fuite aux philippines
depuis trois ans et demi en prison
mission accomplie pour ariane 5 eca
succès vital qui efface les mauvais
souvenirs
la nouvelle fusée a placé sur orbite
deux satellites qu'elle emportait
l'avenir est assuré
et puis demain la fête des amoureux la
saint valentin si vous choisissez de le
dire avec des fleurs ne vous trompez pas
de langage petit lexique à effeuiller en
fin de journal
madame monsieur bonsoir dans l'actualité
de ce dimanche le théâtre de l' empire a
donc été littéralement soufflé par une
explosion à l'aube dans le 17e
arrondissement à paris les enquêteurs ne
privilégient aucune piste ce soir
accidentelle ou criminelle on sait que
des travaux étaient en cours dans ce
haut lieu de la télévision qui avait
perdu peu à peu de sa superbe depuis
l'époque des dimanches de jacques martin
le théâtre allait devenir un hôtel de
luxe karine comazzi médias hier soir
encore c'était un théâtre de 1200 places
aujourd'hui dans ce cratère les pompiers
ont bien du mal à distinguer la scène la
salle et les fauteuils en velours et à
comprendre l'origine de l'explosion d'un
bâtiment qui n'est pas alimentée en gaz
pour le souffle qui est parti un petit
peu dans toutes les directions ils sont
essentiellement donc là sur la façade
principale avenue de wagram et on a
également de trouver sur les façades
latérales seul l'enseigne a tenu bon
l'explosion a légèrement blessé deux
vigiles présents à l'intérieur du
théâtre mais ils sont en état de choc
comme les clients et le gardien de nuit
de l'hôtel situé juste en passe tous les
vitres jusqu'au cinquième étage était
sauvé
vous avez reloger les habitants des
chambres oui on est en train de régler
tout ça n'avait pas l'air emballé
rappelé n'avait pas de blessés
heureusement je vais rentrer chez moi
les enquêteurs de la police judiciaire
n'exclut aucune hypothèse même si selon
eux l'origine de l'explosion serait
plutôt accidentelle le théâtre était
vétuste elle n'avait plus rien de commun
avec la salle de dimanche martin et de
l'école des fans racheté il ya six ans
pour devenir un hôtel de luxe le
bâtiment accueillait hier soir encore un
défilé de mode
il faut voir aussi s'il ya pu avoir un
lien entre cette manifestation d'hier
soir et ce qui s'est passé ce matin
c'est au milieu des gravats que les
enquêteurs doivent maintenant trouver
une explication à cette spectaculaire
explosion digne d'un scénario
hollywoodien remake sans victime de la
tour infernale ce gigantesque incendie à
madrid qui a avalé les 106 mètres d'un
gratte-ciel image particulièrement
impressionnante de sept tours en flammes
dont il ne reste que l'armature on
craint l'effondrement de la structure la
zone a été fermé jusqu'à mercredi
nicolas devise est les flammes
desbordes la cour est devenue infernale
des débris enflammés tombe sur les
équipes de télévision le gratte-ciel
brûlera pendant près de 14 heures
un gigantesque brasier inaccessible face
auquel les pompiers sont impuissants
jusqu'à 1000 degrés au plus fort de
l'incendié le pire qu'ait connu madrid
se gratte ciel est l'un des plus hauts
immeubles de la capitale 106 mètres de
haut
et c'est au 21ème étage que le feu s'est
déclaré la nuit dernière à cause
semble-t-il d'un court-circuit personnes
à l'intérieur il n'y a pas de blessé les
madrilènes affluent en masse
certains croient à un attentat la
première réaction des gens ici ça a été
de penser au 11 septembre
quand vous voyez un immeuble en feu
comme ça heureusement que c'est pas le
cas mais s'est passé tellement de choses
terribles ces derniers temps à madrid
vu du ciel cet après-midi ce n'est plus
qu'une fragile ossature d'où s'échappe
une épaisse fumée une structure très
instable et qui menace de s'effondrer à
tout moment en plein coeur du quartier
financier de madrid le chef du
gouvernement espagnol est venu se rendre
compte de la situation qui est je
voudrais féliciter les pompiers la
police les secours d'urgence et assuré
la mairie quelques poté surtout l'appui
du gouvernement pour surmonter au plus
cette situation difficile
le quartier a été entièrement évacuée il
restera bouclé pendant trois jours au
moins
jean paul ii a repris des forces et met
toute son énergie à donner le change le
pape est apparu à la fenêtre de ses
appartements du vatican
toujours très affaibli il a prononcé la
bénédiction dominicale mais c'est une
autre voix de l'église qui s'est fait
entendre celle ci plus ferme plus
limpide pour notamment écarté toute idée
de démission gérard griesbeck romain
petit jean paul ii a béni la foule à la
fin de l'angélus après dix jours
d'hôpital il est certes diminué mais il
est là à sa finale devant des dizaines
de milliers de pèlerins réunis place
saint-pierre et laden et
le nom est plus ferme que dimanche
dernier mais le pape ne peut prononcé
que quelques mots et nous souhaite avant
dimanche d'entendre sa voix quand même
nom c'est impressionnant de voir qu'il
est toujours là et ils essaient toujours
de parler d'être présent on reste quand
même assez c'est un moment inoubliable
oui bon retour lui souhaite ces pèlerins
et dans son message lu par monseigneur
sandri le pape a dû une fois de plus
qu'il ne renonçait pas à sa charge les
filles elles gardent donc l'espoir de le
retrouver après le caramy il avait de
quoi faire sauter la république disait
ton alfred cervin au coeur de l'affairé
elf n'aura fait aucune révélation il est
mort hier chez lui d'une crise cardiaque
ce personnage qui a trouvé refuge aux
philippines pendant plus de quatre ans
avait été libéré en mai dernier après
avoir passé plus de trois ans en prison
frédéric retard ils avaient menacé de
faire sauter la république mais il
emportera avec lui tous ses secrets
alfred sirven est mort ce matin aux
côtés de vilma une philippine de 30 ans
sa cadette qu'il avait épousé en juillet
dernier ce toulousain cet âge nerfs a
vécu sa vie comme un roman
résistant à 17 ans soldats en corée et
braqueur au japon bras droit de loïk le
floch prigent ancien pdg d'elf épaulé
par christine deviers-joncour sirvin
s'est retrouvé mêlé à l'un des plus gros
scandales de ces dernières années
168 millions d'euros détournés des
caisses du groupe pétrolier français
dont une partie à des fins personnelles
comme l'achat de plusieurs biens
immobiliers entre autres ce château en
indre et loire où cet immeuble que nous
avions retrouvé en plaçant de bruxelles
dans la vie tourmentée d'alfred sirvin
il y à une cavale longue de 4 années et
une arrestation très médiatique aux
philippines l'homme avait assurément un
caractère bien trempé
politique vous savez bien
quand la politique et la finance se
mélangent c'est difficile de s'en sortir
je suis un homme libre
même si j'ai les mains liées je veux
rester fidèle à ma vision des choses
ma vie ma morale les dérives d'altrad
sirvin lui ont valu une condamnation à
cinq années de prison
il en a purgé 3 et attendait le résultat
de l'appel
l'homme qui avait reçu la légion
d'honneur en 93 connaissait tous les
secrets financier et dans son désormais
célèbre carnet le nom des politiques
françaises et étrangers qui ont
bénéficié de ses faveurs un parcours
sans faute pour la fusée ariane 5 qui a
décollé hier soir de kourou en guyane
aujourd'hui c'est le soulagement il n'y
avait pas d'autre voie que le succès
pour donner un avenir à la nouvelle
fusée qui a placé sur orbite les deux
satellites qu'elle emportait patrice
pollet
jean marc nollet fin les ingénieurs
avaient rêvé d'un décollage parfait et
c'est ce qui s'est passé hier soir quand
les 780 tonnes du lanceur se sont
arrachés du pâtis
alors à rien s'est dirigé droit vers
l'espace dans son sillage une traînée de
feu d'une bonne centaine de mètres après
deux minutes de vol
les propulseurs d'appoint se sont
détachés finalement trente et une
minutes après le décollage
les satellites embarqués sont déposées
dans l'espace le plus puissant des
lanceurs européens a parfaitement
fonctionné à couvin au respect ariane 5
ca vient de réussir son retour en vol
effaçant ainsi l'échec de décembre 2002
à evry au siège d'arianespace
satisfaction et applaudissements aussi
le moteur vulcain responsable de l'échec
précédent a donné satisfaction
les responsables du moteur sont contents
c'est un sentiment d'abord grand
soulagement
1 et de fierté quand on a vu ce vol le
magnifique d'ariane 5 est effectivement
le travail considérable qui a été fait
par les équipes d'ingénieurs a permis de
corriger l'anomalie du premier vol 40
satellites à lancer sur une période de
trois ans l'argent va rentrer dans les
caisses
c'est un bénéfice global pour tout le
monde qui représente quand même un
chiffre d'affaires de plus de 1,3
milliard d'euros par an donc c'est
vraiment beaucoup d'argent prochain vol
d'une ariane au mois d'avril avec à bord
le satellite de télécommunications
militaires français syracuse en
allemagne à dresde de manifestation de
plusieurs millier de néonazis qui tente
de récupérer la mémoire des dizaines de
milliers de victimes qui ont péri sous
les bombardements alliés il ya soixante
ans c'est nazi parle de l'holocauste par
les bombes
une réinterprétation histoire qui
entachent les commémorations officielles
sur place jérôme benest brice bout soir
ils ont choisi ce jour de deuil à dresde
pour faire une tentative de récupération
de la douleur ils étaient trois à quatre
milles selon la police
tous les groupuscules néonazis que
compte l'allemagne s'étaient donné
rendez-vous ici aujourd'hui les forces
de sécurité donner l'impression d'une
ville en état de siège
une ville passée au peigne fin chaque
recoin contrôle et de très près chaque
groupe fouillé mission des forces de
l'ordre évitez à tout prix que les néo
nazis ne rentre en contact avec les
contre manifestants dont certains
avaient traversé l'allemagne
pour participer à la moindre
manifestation contre l'allemagne qui est
en mon opinion très dangereux les
dirigeant néonazi multiplie les
provocations
il qualifie le bombardement de dresde il
ya 60 ans par la royal air force
d'holocauste de bombes comme pour le
mettre au même niveau d'horreur que la
shoah
dans la soirée quelques incidents ont
éclaté entre néo nazis et
contre-manifestants les les habitants
ont repris leurs droits devant l'opéra
de dresde pour faire oublier les
extrémistes du npd baie avionique pnvd
n'a rien à faire ici
nous avons assisté hier comme cela
beaucoup ils ont apporté dix mille
bougies pour la mémoire et la chaleur
pour se retrouver ensemble loin des
récupérations politiques en irak est les
résultats officiels des élections ont
été publiés cet après midi le 30 janvier
date du scrutin historique deviendra
d'ailleurs fête nationale pas de vraie
surprise puisque les estimations données
déjà la liste chiite parrainé par
l'ayatollah sistani en tête loïc de la
mornais diego garcia fait la liesse dans
la rue irakienne mais ici nous sommes à
kirkouk fief des cures deux irakiens
après des décennies de souffrances sous
le régime de saddam hussein les kurdes
viennent d'être consacré deuxième force
politique du pays
nous avons tellement souffert de la
dictature et de ce régime fasciste
aujourd'hui nous sommes les grands
vainqueurs longue vie aux kurdes et au
kurdistan le résultat des élections et
sans grande surprise même si elle
n'obtient pas la majorité absolue
l'alliance it de l'ayatollah sistani
arrive largement en tête avec 47% des
voix suivi par les kurdes 25 % puis par
le parti chiite également du premier
ministre sortant ayad allawi la première
liste sunnite n'obtient que 1,7 pour
cent des suffrages un résultat qui
s'explique par le large au boycott des
élections par les sunnites
le taux d'abstention est monté jusqu'à
98% au final le vote reflète plutôt
fidèlement la place des ethnies les
chics l'ont emporté car ils sont les
plus nombreux
les kurdes se sont fortement mobilisés
mais à cause du boycott les 20% de
sunnites sont quasiment absents de la
représentation
si les chiites et les kurdes veulent
éclater le pays
ce sera trop facile bruit pour le faire
si le permettent
mais s'ils veulent garder l'irak unifié
il va falloir qu'ils tentent tous les
deux la une mais magnanime à aux
sunnites
désormais la majorité chiite d'irak peut
aussi compter sur un puissant allié
l'iran voisin chiite également de quoi
compliquer la tâche des tuteurs
américain il leur faudra aussi répartir
les pouvoirs et nommé un chef de l'état
un premier ministre et un président du
parlement en respectant l'équilibré
sortie des urnes et on est toujours sans
nouvelles de flaran souvenait de son
guide disparu le 5 janvier dernier à
bagdad nous pensées vont à leurs
familles je vous rappelle qu'un concert
à l'olympia est organisée demain un
concert de soutien avec charles aznavour
patrick bruel et de très nombreux
artistes au proche orient le processus
de trêve se poursuit avec en signe de
bonne volonté la libération décidé
aujourd'hui par le gouvernement
israélien de 500 détenus palestiniens à
libération qui devrait se faire dans les
jours prochains par ailleurs israël va
remettre les corps de 15 activistes aux
palestiniens de la bande de gaza la
sphère fait du bruit en allemagne
faut-il ou non interdire les tests de
paternité qui se pratique dans les
laboratoires privés à l'insu de la mer
ce sont des personnages qui par des
tests adn sur la salive de leurs enfants
ou présumés tels cherche à obtenir
confirmation ces tests n'ont pas de
valeur
elles me permettent d'entamer une action
en justice jérôme benest brisgau soir
être ou ne pas être le père
telle est la question qui a longtemps
tarauder dieter chauffeur routier
quand on lui a fait remarquer que sa
fille de 8 ans ne lui ressemble et
guerre et il a voulu savoir
je voulais en avoir le coeur net savoir
si j'étais le père ou pas et puis il
fallait donner à l'enfant une chance de
connaître son père m'a alors dit heures
à fait ce que font chaque année 5000
allemand il a acheté en pharmacie un
coffret comme celui ci puis il a pris
l'empreinte adn dans la bouche de
l'enfant avec le coton tige et il l'a
envoyée ainsi que sa propre empreinte un
laboratoire privé
il y en a une quarantaine en allemagne
qui gagnent beaucoup d'argent en faisant
à l'insu des maires des tests adn de
paternité dans 15% des cas analysés
le test prouve l'absence de filiation ce
fut le cas pour dieter il n'était pas le
père les spécialistes estiment que 3 5%
des nouveaux nés en allemagne sont ce
que l'on appelle ici des bébés coucou
allusion aux oiseaux voleurs denis des
enfants élevés par un père qui n'est pas
le leur phénomène exploité par une
chaîne de télévision commerciale dans
l'émission lui ou lui qui est le père
mais le gouvernement allemand voudrait
mettre le holà en interdisant ces tests
faits sans que la mer en soit informé
connaissant la mer je sais qu'elle
n'aurait jamais donné son accord
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai fait
le test en cash et les députés auront
donc sans doute à légiférer sur cette
délicate question de société mais qui
sait combien parmi les hommes qui
siègent qu'ici au bundestag ont déjà
envoyé leur petite éprouvette pour un
test de paternité en france ce mardi
prochain le texte loi d'orientation sur
l'école passe à l'assemblée
l'apprentissage des sciences fait partie
du socle commun des connaissances
seulement voilà les études scientifiques
ne séduisent plus ou moins 30%
d'étudiants en dix ans du coup les
universités essaye de rendre ces
disciplines plus attractives comme à
bordeaux reportage nabila taboury rémy
poissonnier ils sont en terminale
scientifique
et a priori leur voie vers les labos de
recherche est tout tracé
je voudrais insister ingénieur du son et
oui le bac s ne recrute pas que des
scientifiques dans l'âme
et c'est bien là le problème d'ici cinq
ans une pénurie de physiciens
mathématiciens et biologiste s'annonce
alors les universités se mobilisent à
bordeaux pas une semaine sans qu'un
groupe de lycéens le visitent la fac de
sciences favoriser les échanges avec les
étudiants c'est le meilleur moyen de
séduire ces lycéens au moment même où
ils choisissent leur future orientation
nous rassure quant aux élèves qui
veulent un peu comme tu peux travailler
plus ça passe
les lycéens optent pour le droit les
lettres ou les sciences humaines
résultat 30 % d'étudiants scientifique
en moins en dix ans et eu trop longue
des bouchers limitée l'université lutte
contre ces clichés par exemple sur les
modifier
il faut mettre derrière de
l'électronique de des lasers qui sont
des filières en pointe les télécoms etc
au niveau des mathématiques les
mathématiques bien c'est toute la
modélisation mathématique qui va servir
dans tous les secteurs de l'aéronautique
de l'automobile du spatial et c est pour
susciter ces vocations mieux vaut s'y
prendre le plus tôt possible ses élèves
de cm2 ne font pas de théorie les leçons
sont toujours gratifiant
je viens d'apprendre en s'amusant
faisant plein d'espoir et aux frères
plus de leçons jours à voir car c'est
aussi pour nous l'occasion de travailler
sur je dirais d'été des fondamentaux
comme le français les mathématiques sur
d'autres supports que les supports
habituels mais les initiatives de ce
genre défendre encore de la bonne
volonté de l'enseignant or les petits
écoliers d'aujourd'hui pourrait faire
les grands scientifiques de demain
environnement c'est cette semaine
qu'entre en vigueur le fameux protocole
de kyoto septans après son adoption est
très affaiblie par le refus des états
unis d'y adhérer cet accord de réduction
des gaz à effet de serre impose un sacré
effort pour les pays industrialisés la
france a bien du chemin à faire et du
faudra développer davantage ses énergies
renouvelables comme le monde ce
reportage de florence mavic et virginie
travers transformer la formidable
énergie du soleil en électricité
c'est le travail quotidien de ces
ouvriers qui fabriquent des panneaux
solaires photovoltaïques dans le
département de l'isère
on ne chôme pas pendant notre entreprise
que l'europe seulement par la crise et
600 personnes qui travaillent ici et 96%
de production est exportée depuis le 15
janvier nous avons arrêté de travailler
pour la france et pour quelles raisons
pour quelle raison parce que le marché
en france notre développement ces
panneaux photovoltaïques
lusine les vents en allemagne ou en
espagne contrairement à la france ces
pays ont choisi de subventionner
fortement ce type d'énergie solaire en
pleine expansion au niveau dans le même
il ya
mécanismes d'incitation qui oblige les
sociétés d'électricité allemande a
racheté kilowattheure sédentaires ou aux
producteurs
un tarif qui est vraiment très très
intéressant il est trois fois supérieur
au tarif de rachat qui est en vigueur en
france
et pourtant cette énergie verte a tout
pour séduire les panneaux
photovoltaïques fabrique votre
électricité en utilisant la lumière du
soleil et vous revendez ce que vous ne
consommez pas edf mais à un prix trop
faible par rapport au coût
d'investissement de l'installation
les difficultés de la filière
photovoltaïque illustre la lenteur de la
france dans la course aux énergies
renouvelables la part d'électricité
verte est même en train de décroître 18
% en 1990 très et demi pour cent en 2003
on est loin des 21 % fixé par bruxelles
pour 2010 donc ici il va se situer la
première éolienne
une autre va se situer sur notre dos
j'ai loupé leur être utile ce vol en
foot une bonne dose quand on construit
des parcs éoliens
comme ici près de montélimar il aura
fallu sept ans et une action en justice
pour que la société porteuse du projet
obtiennent le permis de construire ont
refusé par le préfet pour atteinte au
paysage
il faut beaucoup plus de volonté
politique pour pouvoir traduire à
l'échelle locale les objectifs que l'on
nous fixe à l'échelle nationale
s'engager dans les énergies
renouvelables relève du parcours du
combattant lenteur des procédures
complexité des dossiers
myriad d'administration ou oppositions
locales pas de quoi doper l'électricité
verte
sauriez vous êtes tester cette formule
concerne les commerçantes de toute une
ville
leur travail est suivi par des clients
qui sont en réalité des enquêteurs et
qui donnent des notes
yvan martin et cindy berkous son visage
vous ne le verrez pas son anonymat et
son gagne pain
il est ce qu'on appelle un client
mystère son métier tester les
commerçants évalué l'accueil l'amabilité
la bonne tenue des boutiques visite type
en caméra cachée
a font un tabac à rouler
assabah super confortable
la boulangère et courtoise souriante
bilan de la visite plutôt positif
voilà la première chose à faire c'est
déjà de bien repérer les lieux donc de
tourner la tête un peu dans tous les
sens pour pour qu'on ait le temps à la
fois de visualiser les produits la
vitrine
comment sont organisées un peu
différents rayons si les allées sont
dégagées et la journée est loin d'être
terminée l'office du commerce d'issoire
a demandé une évaluation continue de ses
250 commerces
objectif mesurer les qualités
commerciales donc et s'assurer que les
détaillants d'issoire sap orienter les
touristes bon et lequel est le meilleur
nous serions nous indique anne hôtel
pour ce soir un commerçant un moment
donné peut interroger sur quelque chose
qui n'a pas de lien direct avec son
activité et le commerçant doit être
capable de renseigner vous êtes
accueillis lors de votre arrivée est
voulu immédiatement salué oui après
chaque visite
une grille détaillée à remplir elle sera
analysée décryptée avant d'être envoyé
aux commerçants et pied à base de toute
façon c'est une bonne initiative à
partir du moment où ça peut améliorer le
rapport avec la clientèle
à moins de points positifs je dis donc
c'est ce regard extérieur de la chose
qui me permet un petit peu de rectifier
certaines erreurs que je peux avoir sur
mon commerce enquêteurs ou mouchard la
ville d'issoire la sueur jusqu'à présent
l'intervention du client mystère
n'aurait provoqué aucun licenciement
parmi les salariés des commerces visite
pour les passionnés de vieilles voitures
le salon rétromobile a ouvert ses portes
ce week end à paris l'occasion de vous
présenter le portrait d'un
collectionneur qui défend ce patrimoine
roulant luc vézina remy poissonnier
un ronronnement presque septuagénaire 7
hotchkiss date de 1938 un modèle
français haut de gamme et surtout
sportif
la marque a gagné six fois le rallye de
monte carlo
claude delagneau collectionne les
vieilles voitures pour mieux voyager
dans le temps et selon lui tout
s'explique même le volant à droite dans
un véhicule pourtant fabriqué en france
les premiers carrossier automobile
étaient des carrossiers hippomobile et
sur les véhicules hippomobiles
le coach était toujours à droite tout
simplement pour surveiller le caniveau
donc naturellement les premiers
carrossier automobile ont fait des
conduites à droit puissent y est habitué
à faire dans leur véhicule hippomobile
le gaucher à droite et le plaisir
aujourd'hui c'est de faire vivre ce
patrimoine roulant il y en a pour tous
les goûts de la populaire quatre chevaux
renault à l'élégante hotchkiss
c'est effectivement un patrimoine
culturel c'est une mémoire industrielle
est la différence avec un tableau c'est
qu'un dimanche sont plus une sculpture
ces classes ça va ça roule ça se bouffe
ça se déplace mais il faut bichonner ses
voitures au quotidien pour réveiller le
lustre d'hier la mondialisation dans
l'automobile ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
ocz qu'ils ont est un nom tout à fait
britannique émigré aux états unis mais
la marque est tout à fait française
puisque installé à saint denis en 1904 à
la fabriquer des voitures jusqu'en 1954
pour leurs 50 ans voyager dans le temps
ça a un prix exemple pour ce petit
modèle la mise de départ
on va dire c'est entre 3 et 4000 euros
et puis après vous pouvez partir sur un
budget annuel entre 400 et 600 euros
des ancêtres qui à chaque jour deux
roues ravive davantage les souvenirs de
notre mobilité
près de pompéi patrimoine de l'humanité
la préservation des sites historiques
est menacé par des pigeons qui ont
colonisé herculanum le mystère de la
culture de passer un contrat avec un
fauconnier dans les rapaces tiennent la
distance les oiseaux isabelle ce test
christophe la rocca au pied du vésuve
dans les ruines d'herculanum dévasté par
l'éruption du volcan en l'an 79
le fauconnier son rapace sont aux aguets
lorsque je trouve un petit groupe de
colombes
je les lâche et les colombes sans fil
car ils sont les gardiens du site
allez hop le faut qu'on chasse colombie
ou pigeons en apparence bien inoffensifs
et qui pourtant cause d'irréparables
dégâts
regardez là ici aussi ils nichent dans
les recoins des vestiges et leur extrême
en rouge des fresques inestimable enfin
il world est en fait les excréments des
pigeons contiennent des substances très
acide qui impacte en profondeur la
peinture la peep toe la main qui on
n'avance pas les mêmes lorsque la fraise
qui reste au risque aussi mis en garde
la crasse ville aussi l'hommage profonde
guitare tandis que la lave du vésuve a
recouvert pompéi herculanum fut enseveli
sous des cendres froides le site et
mieux conservé on y trouve encore des
poutres en chêne noirci mais les pigeons
les picorent les mange et il en reste
peu ici et là mairie m'envoie ok puis
les cimes d'abolir la structure
s'affaiblit les monopoles
donc il faut intervenir pour restaurer
les structures et maisons perd les
poutres d'origine non solomiac et plus
original
la méthode a déjà fait ses preuves sur
les pistes des aéroports italiens
pendant un an
herculanum patrimoine de l'humanité sera
le territoire des rapaces qui a été
sportif du rugby avec la victoire du
quinze de france cet après midi contre
l'angleterre pour la première fois
depuis huit ans les tricolores se sont
imposés à tous canam 18 à 17
il reste dans la course au grand chelem
nicolas geay guillaume viard
c'est le refrain d'une équipe heureuse
les bleus viennent de battre les anglais
à twickenham
huit ans qu'ils attendaient ça huit ans
qu'il n'avait plus gagné en angleterre
c'est désormais chose faite grâce au
talent d'un gamin de 24 dimitri yachvili
buteur au pied dehors et auteur à lui
tout seul des 18 points français quand
je suis bien dans la tête ça rentre donc
tant mieux mais bull tcc aussi
concrétiser surtout concrétiser les
efforts d'aidé coéquipiers donc j'en
suis très fier dès la 4e minute dimitri
yachvili montre la voie aux bleus
la france mène 3-0 à twickenham mais
vexés par leur défaite la semaine
dernière face aux gallois les anglais
pouces et inscrivent deux essais par
barclays d'abord
puis par lewsey à la pause les anglais
mènent 17 6
les vents sont défavorables aux bleus
mais en deuxième mi temps les bleus vont
inverser la tendance
trois coups de patte de dimitri yachvili
permettent au quinze de france de
revenir au score et de reprendre espoir
à dix minutes de la fin
l'angleterre n'a plus que deux points
d'avancé
dans les ultimes minutes dimitri
yachvili ne tremble pas sur cette
pénalité et offre la victoire à l'équipe
de france angleterre 17 yachvili cuisse
avec ce succès les bleus sont idéalement
placés pour réaliser le grand chelem
des histoires de la joie et un peu de
chance comme un présage pour l'équipe de
france dans le calendrier chinois 2005
et l'année du coq depuis 10 tennis avec
est la défaite d'amélie mauresmo en
finale de l'open de paris
mauresmo s'est inclinée face à la russe
dinara safina en trois sets 6 4 2 6 6 3
amélie mauresmo est sûre pour la
troisième fois en finale de l'open du
côté du ciel vigilance orange nous dit
météo france pour une quinzaine de
départements du centre-est et des
pyrénées d'importantes chutes de neige
pourraient se produire la nuit prochaine
en altitude la couche de neige pourra
atteindre de 10 à 30 cm avec une
circulation plus difficile
ceci nous amène aux caprices de la météo
et ses dérèglements climatiques qui sont
le thème du carnaval de nice qui a
commencé ce week-end défi des batailles
de fleurs et l'arrivée du roi du
carnaval pour marquer le début de la
fête
versini tu martic et gaëlle caron ont
vécu la journée aux côtés du plus jeunes
carnavaliers de nice voici le plus
jeunes carnavaliers de nice
yoann a tout juste 20 ans cette année il
a travaillé sur trois chars le défilé
c'est l'heure de la confrontation avec
le public et avec les autres chars du
corso de trois mois jour et nuit
à
l'entièreté de
en trois mois de travail et ce matin
encore les dernières retouches
yoann est complètement dévoué à la tâche
et pour cause être carnavaliers c'est
son rêve de petit garçon lorsque j'avais
12-13 ans j'ai commencé à faire des
chars de carnaval en miniature depuis je
suis tout petit je suis fasciné par le
carnaval et quand quand je commence à
grandir un petit peu je me suis rendu
compte que c'était vraiment quelque
chose qui me passionnait et que je
voulais faire mais vu là dedans
des maquettes au géant de cartographie
la passion est restée intacte droit à
zebra que tous ces chars ils les
protègent
amoureusement pas dire que je m'amuse
pas si faux c'est quand même un travail
il faut être vigilant il faut faire
attention publique pour matériel aux
chars mais c'est c'est un plaisir un
plaisir partagé les spectateurs
apprécient à l'unisson les traits de
magnifiques couleurs et gauche ne sommes
pas mal
et la magie du carnaval
yoann ne dira pas le contraire c'est
qu'il n'ya pas que les spectateurs qui
en prennent plein les yeux
en ces vacances de février les
restaurants d'altitude n'ont pas
toujours bonne réputation
du coup une trentaine d'établissements
suisse et en france joue la carte de la
gastronomie ou presque une vraie bonne
assiette pour les skieurs à l'heure du
déjeuner de quoi redorer l'image de la
cuisine à la neige jean jacques dufour
karl grécourt ketchup snowboard octobre
au fil des années la montagne française
cette américaine mais ils font des reds
aussi sont super mal étreint dès son
personnage
les braqueurs non mais il ya aussi une
histoire de redorer le blason terni de
ces établissements disséminés sur les
sommets les responsables du domaine des
portes du soleil tous deux stations et
220 remontée ont décidé de lancer un
pass gourmand un guide gratuit qui
regroupe une trentaine de restaurateurs
qui montrent leur savoir faire et c'est
une invitation à découvrir notre
patrimoine
on a donc suivre le guide premier arrêt
sur les pistes avec le chef japonais de
la table du marché techniquement la
cuisine française c'est quand même pour
moi c'est la meilleure chose la
meilleure du monde marie tout à fait
alors c'est quoi votre spécialité vous
écoutez moi j'adore travailler poisson
mais quand même c'est un montant ces
variants basse et cochons nous
décrochons soufflé au beaufort jeu les
douces un risotto aux écrevisses sa
cuisine c'est mieux qu'une journée de
glisse cet office peut être pas de fond
du drac est tous à nous pour faire autre
chose que
que sq enquête le monde pour passer d'un
sommet au fond d'une vallée il suffit de
ski ça permet d'avaler des kilomètres de
pistes et d'arriver dans une ferme où
les jambes ont enfumé font saliver avant
même de les avoir goûtés fait quoi dans
la ferme alors là maintenant elle
fromage que vous vendez oui et puis je
te les prochains enjeux fallait changer
sont les bouder dans un hall un beau oui
ferme ou resto rural ou des astros
l'opération pass gourmet c'est
l'alternative au mcdo d'ailleurs pour 15
euros
les estaminets impliqué propose une
assiette ce coeur qui devrait permettre
de se rabibocher avec la gastronomie des
sceaux me passez vous mais c'est nouveau
cette maman c'est une soupe est la
viande fumée avec georges légumes
chou rave c'est ce que manger les gens
tout à fait c'est un produit qui marche
très très bien avec les gens qui
viennent de l'extérieur parce qu'il
découvre justement les remous du terrain
ce qui marche également très bien c'est
le steak de cheval aux peurs de myrte
manger du cheval
nous aimons bien le cheval j'ai vu vous
aviez aussi ils font du au fond oui ça
c'est une création maison
nous l'avons inventé l'année passée
après avoir fait un rôti de porc au
point on devait faire une fondue j'ai
dit on fera qu une fondue original c'est
d'avoir action sur les pistes dans leur
souci ce fait un nom mais nous refusons
de tout ça nous refusons cela étant et
comme vous pouvez le constater à la
montagne comme ailleurs est lié à pâques
des gourmands mais pour ceux qui aiment
manger je peux en témoigner le pass
gourmet permet de déguster bien autre
chose que des frites surget cinéma avec
la sortie mercredi prochain de chuck
dean histoire vraie d'un champion
français de boxe thaïlandaise
dida joue son propre rôle le parcours
d'un mauvais garçon sauvé par la passion
du sport parce qu'elle deschamps eric de
lannion
si un champion mérité un film c'est bien
lui l'histoire de dida 33 ans vice
champion du monde a tout de la succès
story mais sa réussite et surtout celle
d'un jeune homme hors du commun qui
échappe aux clichés de son cv
dida né en banlieue un court séjour en
prison et puis le déclic
le coup de foudre pour la boxe thaï et
puis un coup de tête le départ pour la
thaïlande parce que c'est là bas que ça
se passe didac en 3 pendant trois
semaines devant un club mythique où l'on
ne veut pas de lui boxing on le passe à
l'écran groupe à ela lab a refusé
l'entrée dans le camp pour moi c'était
ok pas aujourd'hui mais je sais que
demain ou un jour rentrer dans le camp
le visiter un peu fou quand même que je
peux dire fou certainement naïf et
inconscient et 75 boxun ce pays rien
j'espère que c'est pas venus faire de la
figuration en trois ans dida devient
champion du monde contre toute attente
grâce sans doute un cheminement mental
bien à nyon
si je me suis colère jamais de véritable
révolte jamais de haine j'essaye d'être
une personne
chaque jour qui passe et j'essaie d'être
de devenir quelqu'un véritablement de
biens et les super g et en thaïlande je
regardais un combat et puis à quelqu'un
qui me tape sur le droid et et van damme
je dis ouais depuis d'ideye devenu plus
qu'une star un modèle et s'il a
raccroché les gants il n'hésite pas à
revenir à la courneuve au club où il a
débuté
c'est quelqu'un qui pour mouler dans la
banlieue en présente quand même quelque
chose de fort c'est un cas a réussi à
passer par la petite porte
j'espère que et il y aura de plus en
plus haut dida est fier de ses origines
fier de ce qu'il a accompli mais il sent
chez ceux qui viennent après lui un
désespoir inquiétant c'est d'esthétique
dans la vie c'est la violence et la
haine cette semaine il pas véritablement
je suis passée par là mais je sais que
ça
au fait ce choc dit ça veut dire bonne
chance on taille dans la vie de dida il
ya eu de la chance mais il n'y a pas eu
ce théâtre avec christina rées a ni sur
la scène du théâtre antoine à paris un
des grands classiques du molière
vénitien carlo goldoni met en scène une
belle aubergiste et ses quatre
prétendants à rôle sur mesure pour
christiana réali la locandiera
personnages truculents et attachante qui
fait tourner les têtes isabelle bechler
bio michel point faible la coquetterie
c'est de me voir servie courtisé très
gâté un peu comme toutes les femmes me
marier je n'y pense même pas la
locandiera est une aubergiste très
accorte du xviiie siècle et florentin
goldoni l'a écrite comme une séductrice
sans beaucoup de scrupules
mais on peut aussi en faire une lecture
plus moderne c'est une petite pédégère
comme ça qui veut faire plaisir à tout
le monde que les gens soient bien les
recevoir qu'ils soient bien accueillis
bien bien traités et évidemment ils
viennent souvent la courtiser mais c'est
pas une vénale quand même bad mali
quel bonheur de pouvoir converser en
toute franchise nous a fait le compte
d'alta fiori tapas clash fortunés qui
est fasciné par la locandiera de par sa
liberté
c'est sur le marquis de forli popoli
aristocrate ruiné et qui n'a rien
d'autre à offrir à la loi me dira que sa
protection
moi je joue fabrizio le valais dalo
candiard et je la convoitent à peu près
depuis l'âge de 5 ans et demi moi je
joue le chevalier de riz paf a atteint
un misogyne déclaré et je suis le seul
homme de la distribution à résister à la
canebière je finis par ramper en bavant
devant elle mais
c'est pour vous laisser pas contre moi
j'espère on ne l'avait lâché triste et
dure est-ce que mon départ une mise en
scène classique un peu tiré vers le
boulevard où toute la truculence de la
comédie italienne sur un plateau c'est
demain la fête des amoureux la saint
valentin qui fait battre les coeurs
alors dites le avec des fleurs mais ne
vous trompez pas de langage attention
scènes de ménage un amoureux prévenu en
vaut deux nicolas le mariner et rémy
posséder
il aime un peu beaucoup passionnément à
la folie c'est sûr alors rien de tel
qu'un bouquet de fleurs pour exprimer
son amour mais lesquels choisir
dans cet exercice délicat les amoureux
ont souvent des goûts très classique
erreur chaque fleur a une signification
un bouquet de primevères cela veut dire
aimons-nous l'espace d'un instant
attention aux gaffes le cyclamen c'est
la fleur du plaisir qui s'est enfui
rupture assuré pour 2 euros 50
le mieux c'est encore de suivre les
conseils d'un spécialiste
alors les fanfarons auront la
possibilité d'offrir les berges d'or qui
veut le dire
j'irai jusqu'au bout de la nuit avec toi
ici on a associé des des piments le
piment qui voudra dire je brûle d'amour
pourquoi l'on peut aussi faire des
déclarations plus romantiques comme par
exemple des personnels qu'ils veulent
dire ton amour à dégeler mon coeur au
rayon très chic des orchidées le sabot
de vénus fera de la femme désirée une
déesse et pour ceux qui ne roulent pas
sur l'or pour les petits budgets
latulippe toute simple c'est l'amour
sincère bref il y a des centaines de
fleurs et autant de façon de déclarer sa
flamme c'est compliqué il faut de
l'entraînement
c'est vrai après tout fin seul jour
c'est un peu court pour maîtriser l'art
subtil de la déclaration d'amour flot sa
fin de ce journal je remercie de votre
attention dans un instant à météo
nathalie rihouet 20h50 votre film
l'ombre d'un soupçon avec harrison ford
00h40 le journal de la nuit
7h40 demain dans les 4 vérités relance
car soit dominique bussereau 13 heures
benoît duquesne batteur david pujadas et
puis demain soir demain soir complément
d'enquêté avec benoît duquesne sur les
risques industriels exempte fin de
soirée sur france 2